ce matin devant les locaux de pôle
emploi
l'heure est à l'inquiétude en cause la
réforme de l'assurance chômage et le
durcissement des règles d'indemnisation
ça nous met des barrières de dire on va
travailler on va travailler on va
travailler pis si un jour on se retrouve
au chômage
on va pas percevoir beaucoup désormais
il ne faudra plus travailler quatre mois
mais six en deux ans pour toucher une
allocation
idem pour les droits rechargeables
actuellement si un chômeur travail un
mois il a droit un mois d'indemnités
avec la réforme il lui faudra travailler
pendant six mois pour relancer ses
droits je trouve c'est compliqué parce
que va trouver un travail pour six mois
c'est pas forcément donné à tout le
monde quand on est jeunes souvent on n'a
plus eu en cdd d'un mois deux mois
renouvelable ou pas dès le 1er novembre
sur les 2,6 millions de chômeurs 41%
verront leurs allocations diminué et 9%
perdront leur droit pour les
associations et syndicats cette réforme
est injuste
les faudra qu'ils soient obligés
d'accepter les emplois dont les salariés
ne veulent pas parce que c'est des
emplois ou les horaires sont éclatées
des horaires très difficile le matin la
nuit les week-ends quand on une vie de
famille ou bien des salaires mal payés
avec cette réforme le gouvernement
prévoit d'économiser 3 9 milliards
d'euros d'ici à 2022